welcome to this video and P go and pee
go spain spanish flick okay let's play
some flank opening could easily
transpose to him cat alone or stay
within the retina opening yeah maybe
stay within the Reggie with be three
this is an opening that sometimes yeah
it's this is believed to be not very
exciting yeah I mean I I understand the
point but it very often leads to
exciting positions later it is some we
will see what exactly happens here but I
have some ideas and those in this
opening that are really aggressive and
we will see what happens yeah here for
example this won't be a bomb p.m. a
boring position at or because white has
this nice center I maybe could have
played NIDA a FOIA taking this Bishop
interesting okay some centralized first
I'll kanokon IG for something weird hmm
my looks really weird look g one rook d
one tries to discourage c5 yes I wanted
to and use this kind of move and also I
would love to play d4 d5 in response to
c5 is this possible maybe try to yeah it
is technically possible if i go here c5
i can go d5 yeah it should be should be
possible ed cd95 Bishop before it is CD
bishop d 5 rupee 595 Bishop c4 maybe he
can play a text a group the idea this I
probably should have considered a bit
more carefully yeah now i have f 384 if
everything else fails i can do that but
but there might be entirely different
ideas because this is a this position
that black hairs is somewhat shake here
let's think about it like we should be
494 night s7 know this is kind of this
kind of business is very close to
working also takes takes Queen g4 this
Knight f6 hmm
I always have f3 and your form I don't
see something super convincing after the
capture here takes takes Queen g5 this
Queen h5 sg6 and that's not really
leading to that much okay I'll just push
this back form bonds in the center when
night g5 can even play H for winning the
piece so II for now very weird kind of
position with all those pieces placed in
the center you know but Joey this is a
this is some a big center that white has
and as I somehow had promised it led to
an interesting position yeah that's not
boring at all we have all pieces on the
board and a huge conflict in the center
is going on and frankly speaking I think
white is in good shape yeah this must be
quite good with all those pawns I don't
know maybe you should just take on d5 CT
exam but I have a nice set type I
definitely like to be white here in this
position I have much more space
and one very important point is said on
c6 this is the glaring weakness yeah if
the bishop is ever moving like to a 6
for example then 96 is very serious and
those those nights are also on d6 and f6
standing on each other's tears I mean
not so not so well uncoordinated yeah I
don't know what black should do here not
that is lost or anything but it's very
uncomfortable position to play now it's
not easily coming up with the move as
well yeah this kind of thing is
certainly logical trying to undermine my
big Center ok I can take I can just take
it 6 cm or I can play you know what is
interesting Bishop h3 is interesting
using the pin along this diagonal
intending to take on e6 yeah that's
that's an interesting move i'm going for
that if yeah it takes if we get our way
to wait a moment here this also d6 in
this position d 6 45 t6 route takes rope
chains and it as a five wins apiece
okay d 6 he will probably just drop back
I don't know come on I don't want to be
too fancy here yeah I'm threatening just
to take on his six and take on c4 with
the good position according to the keep
it simple attitude I wasn't sure about
d6 maybe he could have just retreated to
evade and then it's it's not that
brilliant young came here just winning
this pawn now maybe Queen B 7 ok didn't
do that to just keep things a little bit
more complicated check ok would be one
will trade iam it's just check simplify
the position a bit
you know he has a sip on but it's not
really moving and I intend to play this
move which trades bishops now it really
trades bishops because he has played g5
and here the simple thing to do is to
just go to deform and pick up the pick
up this high morning yeah probably here
Knight takes Knight takes is a very
simple win check oh okay check let's
know this is a perfect locate of the
pawn and they can just push enf porn
check
no I said nothing to do here for black
black resides it's um yeah it was a nice
position that some emerged he I'm still
curious if there is some technical thing
going on no the comp wants to play
exactly as I played or almost it wants
to play a three and now it wants to play
Bishop h3 immediately hmm that makes
some sense it's not totally necessary to
play you fry and Bishop h3 is just wrong
but this also looks quite okay yeah he
takes d5 forever yeah this is the
difference yeah okay I understand Bishop
here is just stronger because he just
simply will not have the chance now to
take on d5 yeah okay that sets really
strong that's stronger than my move it
will lead to a very comparable position
but it does not allow here this wasn't
good but he could have taken him and
then we just proceed and I don't I
didn't succeed in giving him this week
pawn so this would have been much better
let's say I would have taken with this I
guess maybe b5 and then we continue for
me this position it's not clear at all I
am I mean probably objectively speaking
white should be fine because of this big
Center but black has its counter play
with the porn cm tricky tricky business
a tricky position and here yeah after
this I really should be bet I am yeah
the compass 1.6 1.7 and climbing okay
here oh I actually missed something
great Ian I have seven is even stronger
okay I wasn't looking for this kind of
brutal tactics here at the moment it's
very strong yeah King takes Bishop be
six wins the Queen and if he moves the
rock I mean this is like a carnage a
total destruction yeah I was only seeing
that this is like strategically
fantastic yeah because I get to take
here and this is just overwhelming good
for white but um okay I didn't think
about nine f7
and let me was this any good yeah Bishop
ivania like just drops back I mean here
here I'm winning winning material but it
he can just go back and it's not so
clear that I have accomplished much note
that now this is biding on Grenada and I
think it's really better to just go for
this this good structure here with the
capture it should be really nice oh look
these three years a better defense but
still still good for white and here this
is fantastic for what I think this is
almost almost winning unless you you
blunder blunder material it should be
and it should be winning guaranteed gets
to very simple technical stage yeah all
right thanks for watching